this is the oldest version of minecraft
look at how bland it is
it's so old there's no hunger bars what
how are we gonna do stuff and our goal
for this video is to beat the game
we can't even do it on normal mode oh
you can't sprint oh my god it's so
cringe
oh i have to walk all the way over there
wait look at the weird shadow look at
the shadow
what happens if i walk in it ambient
lighting didn't exist back
then it's just like no sun torque kill
the cow we need food
got leather i didn't get any food great
wait i think only pigs
give food dude the water's so much more
blue in this version oh i found pigs
the pigs don't drop anything let's focus
on getting some tools first
wait turn around chris hurry this is
important
i can't throw eggs huh nerd the end
wasn't a thing in the first version of
minecraft
which is why our definition of beating
the game is killing a gas in the nether
i made the first crafting table
i didn't see it in the achievement chat
no you didn't dude you can't even the
crafting the crafting's horrible
you can't even like drag stuff has
anyone got food
no we're making a sword so that way we
can get food oh i found coal let's go
and then there's four swords for the
boys swords for the boys let's go get
some food
wait wait really quick come back come
back i have something way better and
more exciting than sword
yeezys we can't see them
you can't see my armor you kept saying
yeezys we were like what
all right i'm gonna go slaughter these
cows death to all the cows
oh wow we just get double the leather
that's cool i guess
you don't even have to chew you just
absorb it
you just absorb it oh my god this cow
will undie
this cow's been dead for so long i'm
sorry
it's time to mine look how much simpler
it is when you press
f3 why can't it just be like this in
current minecraft these were much
simpler times
skies it's getting dark oh no oh boy
we need to meet up oh god we need
torches all right so come to my cave at
the coordinates of
me and jimmy are already in a kid yeah
come to us i literally
can't see anything it is so dark right
now chandler chris we need to beat up
hold on i'm getting ironed for the boys
i don't see any mobs yet i'm hanging out
on this tree for the rest of the night
i'm all alone
bro i just got blown up by a creeper oh
man
there's so many mobs and i can't sprint
i'm just getting
bullied wow come in my hole
chandler dude i can't do it right now
i'm so far away
oh chris chris i'm getting attacked i'm
getting attacked no why'd you leave the
house i'm not i'm coming back i'm done
seal the hole seal our hole
sorry you're just gonna die open the
hole i'm here
all right i'll open it jump in jump in
come in the hole come in the hole
go in the hole i can't run i'm literally
never gonna find you guys
chandler i'll take you to your hole yeah
we gotta go jimmy we gotta go find that
all right channel you be the decoy go
go go go go go ow get away oh there's
creepers
get to the water oh this was a mistake
oh my gosh spiders are faster than you
in this
we're gonna win this for the viewers the
viewers are sick of seeing us lose we're
not bad at minecraft
we might be bad at old minecraft oh my
gosh taylor has like three creepers
chasing him
don't leave him there i led them in here
i left them
ah all right let's see let's see here
though
wait chilly are you trying to break that
block yeah i gotta oh oh
oh my gosh chandler i just heard an
explosion chandler blew our base open
help
oh what the what did you do just seal it
off just seal it up
oh there's more get out get out get out
get out of the way
move seal it off i'm doing all the hard
work here you guys are trying to
just ran in and nuked us you told me to
come here throw me
a pickaxe there you go
hey don't pick up my stuff by the way
guys i found this iron sword on the
ground
no i've been grinding so hard
give give give oh oh
i can do this all day i i threw it i
threw this i want all my stuff
stop stop stop i literally threw the
sword
i had uh two stacks of torches i don't
have those those are back there
oh they're here they're right here oh
it's invisible for me yeah you were
trying to kill me over it
i just assumed you picked it up because
there's nothing there to make another
portal you need obsidian so me and all
the boys are currently digging straight
down trying to find some diamonds
digging straight down
the best thing to do i hear water ooh
might be near a cavern
so i just dug into a cave guys oh yeah
this is a big cave
oh there's chandler i found lava i found
lava all right so now we're going
on the diamond hunt oh
i just noticed carl screams like a girl
oh there's lava all around here that's a
good sign for diamonds are we shirts
oh lava yeah this is the this is the
place it smells of diamonds here see
this is my version of minecraft this is
when it was fun it was simple hey who am
i who am i
back in my team shut up i stopped
playing a 1.8
back in my day we used to fight people
with other people we need to find the
diamonds
i can't wait to find diamonds truth be
told
i'm literally just digging in a straight
line give me diamonds
okay that's it whoever finds a diamond
first gets a hundred thousand dollars
from jimmy oh
oh carl you're gonna put up 100k from
jimmy
[Music]
oh my god
oh he found diamonds wait wait wait wait
how many how many how many how many have
it
one oh that's a two three four that's a
four
quad
six on six on oh we got six diamonds
baby
okay promise me you won't die with them
what promised me you won't die i can't
make that promise
chandler give me three i'm right here
promise me if he dies you'll pick it up
there's a lot of love they might burn
get away from god hold on there's a lot
of lava down here i'll go get some water
give me sticks okay i have crafting
table
hey don't mind me guys i'm just walking
down my long tunnel
hey you boys making a bunch of obsidian
there's lava underneath coral there's
lava underneath i'm not standing on him
oh you can't give him an attitude when
he tries to protect you
did jimmy turn around
[Music]
i don't see you wait you can't see me
wait that you're there yeah
we really are playing the oldest version
of minecraft carl how many pieces do you
have
i have three i have seven i have seven
all right how many days does it take for
two guys to mine some obsidian
we definitely have more than enough to
be clear all right everybody back to
spawn
goodbye cave that we used to get
diamonds we'll never see you again guys
come to me i have the stairway up
i landed in water what
all right where are we building it i'm
building it right now can somebody torch
me up
whatever we don't have is we're just oh
man
oh wait get him away from the nether
portal get him away get him away
oh god it's scaly watch out i got a
build i'm building a building
90s pulling 90s 390s gentlemen yes
are you ready for war i don't think we
are but let's go
chris yes think of tucker i'm thinking
chandler think of your dog oh carl
think of your girlfriend i don't have
one maybe you'll get one
if you beat this nether okay all right
now let's blow this popsicle sand
i'm lighting it ready guys cowabunga
and we're teleporting let's do it
get out of here i can't fit all right
we're in the nether okay
all right we're in gentlemen we have to
kill one of these guys here
to beat the game because like i said
there's no ender dragon and here's the
thing about the nether
if you die you're done for good
operation kill gas delta 49ers now
underway
carl you know what to do let's go oh
that gas is dying from the lava let's
get him
all right go go go go go go coral shoot
that gas over there i can't reach the
arrows don't reach that far
oh oh oh oh i almost fell to my death
i'm going for a guest
i'm just trying to find a good one oh
god chris we should stick together
ah they just appear you can't see their
blast in this version of minecraft carl
over here you gotta go we gotta go for
this one chandler chandler show me where
where me and jimmy are go for this one
that way we can diversify
and not all die together
chandler you're on fire back it's right
there
i'm dead chandler died all right
it's okay it's so scary because you
don't even see them shoot
chris this one's in lava go go go
where are you guys where are you guys
we're at the gas oh there's so many gas
over here they're ganging on us why did
we give carl all our arrows oh he's
coming for me
oh okay nevermind all right bye there's
one down there he's swimming you
swimming
oh i'm shooting him yes
girl killed him i saw it hey girl
carl we won i'm so good we just beat the
oldest version of minecraft
yes we finally got a victory for once we
did it finally take that 12 year old
version of minecraft you didn't stand a
chance
we're better than you and if you're not
already hit that subscribe button like i
said in the last video we're picking
someone random that subscribes and
giving them ten thousand dollars there's
only a few days left so you
haven't already hit that subscribe
button you can win 10 grand goodbye bye